on soutient les les policiers depuis
jeudi depuis le début des manifestations
mais ça c'est en venimeux jeudi depuis
l'annonce du 49-3 donc on est derrière
l'ensemble des collègues alors au niveau
live quand vous voyez ces images vous
dites quoi déjà il y a deux choses on
entend beaucoup le mot black bloc et on
entend pas beaucoup sur les plateaux
mais c'est pas forcément des Black Blocs
faut faire attention entre le bloc qu'on
connaît depuis trois ou quatre ans
maintenant aujourd'hui qui d'ailleurs
heureusement à certaines manifestations
ont été là parce que je peux vous jurer
qu'il y aurait eu beaucoup plus de
blessés dans les civils là il y a
beaucoup de jeunes qui mettent du noir
moi je vais pas te mentir Cyril tu vois
aujourd'hui j'étais comme ça en
manifestation je vais te faire voir et
je vais t'expliquer pourquoi j'étais
comme ça en manif tissu comme ça on va
dire que je suis un black bloc là on
dira que sur un black bloc aujourd'hui
malheureusement moi tu vois ma tronche
elle est partout et puis il y a certains
policiers bah s'il pouvait l'esquinter
il laisse qu'un trait aujourd'hui ça se
passe comme ça donc maintenant il y a
des gens qui se couvrent le visage parce
qu'ils mettent feu à des poubelles et
des choses comme ça il y a une montée de
la violence ça fait quatre ans qu'on le
dit qu'il va avoir volonté de la
violence aujourd'hui le gouvernement
tout le tissu démocratique il l'a pas
respecté il n'a pas respecté par aucun
moyen et quand il a vu qu'il allait
perdre il a passé un 49-3 donc il y aura
une montée de la violence et on l'avait
dit alors on a dénonce ma ligne évitable
inévitable parce que tous ces citoyens
aujourd'hui bah ils ont un problème
c'est que même quand il passe par le
tissu démocratique ils sont pas écoutés
alors comment ils font alors on voit
démonter de la violence qui va monter
crescendo et attention monter de la
violence peut-être chez les citoyens
mais de votre côté aussi dans la police
on oublie de dire qu'il y a un SDF qui
s'est fait massacrer hier on oublie de
dire que la brave M a écrasé les jambes
d'un citoyen qui était à terre alors
qu'il a bien vu qu'ils étaient là on
fait pas voir les images aujourd'hui des
gens qui étaient totalement pacifistes
qui se sont fait exploser la gueule
aujourd'hui par les forces de police par
les ordres qui sont donnés par cette
milice et la milice et la milice
gouvernementale tout ça on le dit pas
donc malheureusement oui la violence
c'est triste hein mais elle va monter
des deux côtés et si le gouvernement
désamorce pas tout ça ça va être ça va
être terrible et moi j'annonce je le dis
à tout le monde si ça s'arrête pas que
le gouvernement réagit pas on va finir
par avoir des morts il va y avoir des
morts et c'est triste mais ce
gouvernement fait la source d'oreille je
rappelle à tout le monde que pendant le
discours d'Emmanuel Macron il a quand
même osé dire hier imaginez-vous les
smicards n'ont jamais eu autant de
pouvoir d'achat mais c'est une honte
totale d'entendre ça et ben oui il y a
des gens qui sont en colère des gens qui
ont marre de subir cette violence d'État
aujourd'hui dans la rue et
malheureusement ça risque de monter
crescendo alors on va voir justement une
scène très violente aussi il y a déjà de
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
qui sont aussi très fréquents il y a on
avait montré le SDF enfin voilà quand
vous en avez parlé on va parler mais là
c'est un policier qui en a fait les
frais avant d'être évacué inconscient
par ses collègues
et ça vous le condamnez
aujourd'hui si vous cherchez à
responsable il est là où à l'Élysée il
faut aller taper sur les responsables et
je vous invite d'ailleurs à appeler ce
responsable parce que c'est le
responsable de tout ce qui se passe dans
la rue vous savez moi mais 68
malheureusement le gouvernement
n'écoutait pas le peuple ça c'est fini
comment pas avec des bouquets de roses
et si ça continue ça va finir comme ça
malheureusement parce que ce
gouvernement n'écoute pas les citoyens
ça fait 4 ans qu'on le dit sur ce
plateau on arrête pas de le dénoncer
aucune évolue au niveau est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment que le gouvernement va
revenir en arrière c'est pratiquement
impossible mais il a pas le choix si le
gouvernement revient pas en arrière
Cyril sincèrement je suis désolé de dire
ça aujourd'hui et j'aimerais franchement
j'aimerais tellement pas dire ça il va
se passer un drame il va se passer un
drame si ce gouvernement n'écoute pas le
peuple il y a 70% de la population qui
était contre cette réforme pourquoi on
va jusqu'au bout pourquoi on continue de
les écraser avec le pied comme ça sur la
tête et à force de pas les écoutez vous
savez il y a des gens aujourd'hui moi la
plupart des gens que j'ai rencontré ils
m'ont dit j'ai jamais manifesté jamais
tous les jeunes qu'on voit dans la rue
ils ont jamais manifesté et aujourd'hui
bah ouais ils se couvre le visage parce
que bah ils prennent les poubelles il
les brûle pour être entendu pour être
visible pour qu'il se passe quelque
chose il y a eu 3 millions 500000
personnes dans la rue le gouvernement
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a été jusqu'au
bout il a passé le 49-3 quand est-ce que
ce gouvernement va réagir moi je vais
vous le dire jamais c'est bien là qu'il
est le problème jamais et on va arriver
à des effets terribles en France
terrible regardez ce qui vient de tomber
une image complètement hallucinante
c'est presque en direct ça se passe à
Bordeaux la porte entrée de la mairie a
pris feu les pompiers sont sur place
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mieux compliqué bah c'est incroyable ces
images il y a aussi une boutique SFR qui
a été détruite et dépouillée par des
Black Blocs d'ailleurs vous allez nous
dire ce que c'est regardez c'est pas des
Black Blocs
[Musique]
on saura jamais moi j'ai pas vu les
images je sais pas qui a attaqué ça mais
en tout cas vous étiez avec des Black
Blocs cet après-midi ouais bien je suis
monté en tête de cortège alors des Black
Blocs il y avait des gens cagoulé et
vous disent quoi ils nous disent qu'ils
arrêteront pas et qui vont aller
jusqu'au bout et aujourd'hui
malheureusement je le répète le
gouvernement réagit pas si on passe pas
par ça par contre j'espère qu'il y aura
pas une montée un degré supérieur parce
que moi je l'ai connu pendant les gilets
jaunes et ce qui risque de se passer et
s'il m'entendent je les appelle et
surtout faut pas qu'ils passent par là
pas les vitrines de commerçant ne
touchez pas aux voitures c'est super
important parce que c'est des citoyens
de l'autre côté maintenant il va y avoir
du dégât et il est inévitable il est moi
je me rappelle pendant les gilets jaunes
on a une préfecture qui a brûlé il y a
eu des péages qu'on brûlé je me rappelle
de ce qui s'est passé et on est en train
de répéter la même chose et aujourd'hui
il se servent de vous parce que la
dernière rempart contre le gouvernement
c'est la police vous savez avant la
police on les appelle les gardiens de la
paix aujourd'hui vous êtes devenus les
forces de l'ordre moi il y a encore
trois jours j'étais dans un commissariat
il y a trois de vos collègues qui sont
venus me voir pour me dire continue
comme ça par contre il faut pas mélanger
la police qui est dans les commissariats
et la police qui est déployée pour le
match de Lord rien à voir parce que il y
a certains policiers par exemple ceux
qui ont attaqué le SDF est-ce qu'il
s'ensuit je sais pas où vous allez la
recruter ces gens-là mais ils ont un
gros problème quand on va exploser des
tronches et après on s'étonne de prendre
des cailloux sur la tête mais il faut
pas s'étonner il faut pas s'étonner
malheureusement faites le maintien de
l'ordre correctement et arrêter de
défendre un petit peu ce gouvernement
qui vous envoie devant parce que c'est
vous êtes en train de salir votre image
sincèrement au niveau qu'est-ce qui va
se passer dans les prochains jours après
les téléspectateurs qui nous regardent à
20h57 on est en direct au niveau des
citoyens engagés et très en colère on a
vu un la violence monte et on a vu ces
images à Bordeaux vous pouvez les
laisser derrière un derrière les images
de Bordeaux le mettre ça voilà merci euh
voilà soyez réactif un petit peu merci
voilà et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on a vu encore une escalade
c'était tout à fait c'est on a vous avez
senti vous sur le terrain que là
aujourd'hui il y avait encore parlé en
colère plus de violence alors il y avait
il y a une escalade il y avait beaucoup
de monde et on sent cette tension en
fait qui est là qui est en train de
monter et à l'entrain de monter de jour
en jour en fait moi je vous dis j'ai
démarré à Lyon ça a démarré doucement il
y a de plus en plus de monde dans la rue
beaucoup plus de jeunes on se rappelle
quand même dans l'histoire française
quand les jeunes sont sortis commencent
à finir il faut que tout le monde se
rappelle et se remettre ça en tête et
moi je vois je vois pas une descente de
tout ça moi je pense que ça va
s'amplifier parce que le gouvernement
reste sourde oreille je vous rappelle le
discours d'hier d'Emmanuel Macron
regardez un peu ce qu'il se dit sur les
réseaux sociaux il a enflammé auriez
voulu qu'ils disent quoi Emmanuel Macron
comment vous auriez voulu qu'il dise
quoi Emmanuel Macron alors premièrement
alors il y a un problème de réforme je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord avec ça
ce que vous auriez aimé qu'ils disent
alors premièrement il y a un problème de
réforme aujourd'hui on est tous d'accord
là-dessus parce que 70% du peuple n'en
voulait pas mais il y a un problème
qu'on entend pas assez parlé les gens
n'arrivent plus à bouffer aujourd'hui je
le disais sur ce bateau exactement je
disais qu'on allait devant une crise
sociale
on est proche tous les deux c'est ce que
je te dis depuis des mois et je te dis
je pense que la retraite bien sûr que ça
joue mais c'est c'est surtout que c'est
ça c'est c'est beaucoup que les gens
n'arrivent plus à s'en sortir n'arrive
plus à bouffer exactement c'est ça
exactement mais quelle mesure ont été
prises Cyril aujourd'hui aucune mesure a
été prise vous savez on est toujours moi
j'essaye de regarder un petit peu plus
loin de nos frontières nos voisins
espagnols quand ils mettent la TVA à 0 %
sur les produits de première nécessité
pour qu'on le fait pas pourquoi il y a
pas des mesures qui sont prises urgent
tu me dis ce que tu que tu en penses ce
que tu étais sur le terrain j'ai le
sentiment que les Français se disent
actuellement de toutes les façons on est
tellement dans la merde que ça pourra
pas être pire donc
on veut on veut passer par un voilà on
veut passer par une révolution bah tu
sais Cyril il y a un truc si je dois
dire j'ai parlé avec beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui mais il y a un truc qui m'a
vraiment marqué c'est un monsieur qui
avait à peu près 45 ans justement il
m'expliquait qu'il arrivait plus à
bouffer qu'il enfin qu'il arrivait plus
avancer et il a fini avec les larmes aux
yeux sincèrement je suis quelqu'un qui
qui prend vraiment les choses à cœur
avec les larmes aux yeux en me disant
bah j'ai plus rien à perdre pour essayer
de sauver mes gosses et mes
petits-enfants savais quand vous
commencez à entendre ça dans la rue il
faut s'inquiéter il faut vraiment
s'inquiéter quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement bah la réponse qu'on a eu
hier depuis des mois il y a rien du tout
c'est le néant total aucun désamorçage
alors j'en viens me poser la question
que cherche Emmanuel Macron vraiment
dans ce pays qu'est-ce qui cherche
vraiment qu'est-ce qui cherche alors on
va voir cet après-midi on a pu voir
l'image d'une charge policière
particulièrement violente regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ces images très très violentes
qui réagissent actuellement Jean-Michel
oui non je voulais juste savoir s'il y
avait pas une sorte quand même un peu
d'hypocrisie dans le sens que vous
condamnez les violences des deux côtés
et ça on comprend très bien mais est-ce
que dans votre fort intérieur est-ce que
vous souhaitez pas un peu le cas où vous
avez rappelé mes 68 est-ce que vous le
souhaitez pas ce chaos en disant que
c'est la seule solution j'en ai
ressortir de cette réforme Jean-Michel
la meilleure des solutions qu'on appelle
en fait depuis des mois et je l'ai dit à
mathématrise parce que sinon ça l'a
amené justement le chaos c'est avoir une
écoute des citoyens mais on n'a jamais
eu cette écoute et Delphine était là
enfin je l'ai répété mille fois Cyril
ce que je veux t'expliquer aujourd'hui
Jean-Michel c'est que on l'a répété
plein de fois ils l'ont pas fait et
aujourd'hui les gens vont être là oh
c'est bizarre c'est le bordel dans la
rue faut arrêter de s'étonner faut
arrêter de mentir en fait donc la seule
solution c'est le cas maintenant si le
gouvernement ne réagit pas là maintenant
tout de suite oui parce que sincèrement
Jean-Michel j'ai vraiment peur d'avoir
un gamin sur le carreau dans les jours
qui viennent sincèrement parce que ça on
va finir comme ça
21h02 Olivier olive qu'est-ce qui se dit
dans les rangs des manifestants et
qu'elle va être la montée de la voilà de
du mouvement dans les prochains jours
bah en fait ce qu'il dit c'est très
simple c'est que les jeunes ils sont
sortis les papas ils sont en train de
les rejoindre parce qu'il y a eu des
images abominables et des choses
abominales qui sont passées aujourd'hui
sont en train de concentrer tout le
monde d'ailleurs même jusqu'au syndicat
j'ai vu certains blocages qui commencent
à devenir assez dur on sent qu'il y a
vraiment une montée ouais ce qu'il y a
de différent avec les gilets jaunes
c'est que là il y a les jeunes qui sont
là il y a tous les travailleurs qui sont
dans la rue il y a ça concentre vraiment
tout le monde donc tout ce qui risque de
se passer c'est une catastrophe je le
répète plein de fois ce soir parce que
faudra pas s'étonner s'insurger quand
elle va arriver et aujourd'hui je le
répète encore Emmanuel Macron ne réagit
pas et ne réagir pas Emmanuel Macron
vous vous sentirez coupable comment
c'est un bain de sang vous vous sentirez
coupable ou pas du tout ouais parce que
je me dirais que malgré tout ce qu'on a
fait tout ce qu'on a milité on a pas
réussi à faire plier le gouvernement
pour qui ait une vraie réponse
gouvernementale et pour moi ouais c'est
un échec c'est un échec et c'est pour
soi que je me bats depuis des mois pour
pas qu'on en arrive au cas où je peux
pas expliquer à ma gamine que pour y
arriver il faut le chaos je peux pas je
peux y arriver à ça alors au niveau
livre en fait moi je vais essayer d'être
l'avocat du diable ou du tyran ou de la
dictature macroniste il y a moins d'un
an il y a une élection présidentielle
vous êtes d'accord que a gagné cette
élection pas
ensuite il y a une élection législative
il a obtenu une majorité relative
relative non mais relative quand même il
est quand même devant le rassemblement
national et avec sa majorité relative
elle était obligé de passer le 49-3 ok
donc là vous avez un bonnet où il y a
marqué démission donc exactement
imaginons aujourd'hui que Emmanuel
Macron démissionne donc on refait des
élections qui va gagner en fait alors
qui va gagner est-ce que Mélenchon avec
le bordel qu'il faut à l'Assemblée vous
pensez qu'il en ligne alors Marine Le
Pen elle va aller où elle va aller déjà
dit politique actuelle mais moi je pense
que le système est arrivé à bout je
pense que la Cinquième République arrive
à bout et j'espère qu'on pourrait fonder
la première démocratie dans ce pays et
ça serait vraiment super intéressant
très honnêtement parce que tous les
politiques actuelles on voit qu'en fait
tout le contraire je voudrais que les
citoyens votent plus moi je voudrais
qu'on essaie de s'accaparer un petit peu
du système suisse et quand il y a des
grandes décisions à prendre dans ce pays
et puis aborder référendum et révolution
faut faire des référendum faut mettre en
place les voleurs
d'accord
moi moi je pense d'abord et tu le sais
je pense d'abord au peuple et aux gens
qui j'ai qui font que qui fait que
chaque jour qui passe ils sont de plus
en plus dans la merde moi j'ai envie
d'une solution rapide aussi pour eux
voilà que les mecs qui sortent un peu de
la merde qui sortent qui qui parce que
quand ils font grève les mecs croyez pas
à la fin du mois je peux te dire que ça
pique euh il faut un désamorçage du
média je suis bref un désamorçage
immédiat déjà après les référendums tout
ça on verra mais là déjà on parle de ce
qui se passe actuellement exactement
c'est un désamorçage immédiat parce que
là sur le pouvoir sur la réforme moi
j'ai eu des appels toute la journée de
gens qui me disent on n'ose plus sortir
on a peur on sait pas comment on
[Musique]
bah non je pense moi je pensais vraiment
qu'il allait la faire c'est c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai pas voté
Emmanuel Macron on a eu des élections
alors j'entends Géraldine nous dire oui
Emmanuel Macron il est passé Emmanuel
Macron il est passé parce qu'il avait
Marie de Le Pen en face de lui non mais
on va pas refaire le sketch on connaît
tous le sketch on sait tous comment ça
s'est passé
il est passé mais il est pas
représentatif Mathieu c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre aujourd'hui tu as pas 51
% de la population tu as pas 51 % de la
population qui soutiennent Emmanuel
Macron juste
pour c'est jamais arrivé dans une
déduction
qu'un président soit à 51% premier tour
en Afrique non non mais c'est jamais
arrivé juste Reda quand vous entendez
Olivier Olivier veut dire ça va être de
plus en plus chaud vraiment il faut que
ça bouge vite est-ce que vous avez peur
on n'a pas peur on est entraîné pour ça
je veux quand même répondre sur
plusieurs sujets parce que vous avez
beaucoup parlé mais j'aurais bien voulu
répondre au moins pour défendre mes
collègues faut savoir une chose déjà
très importante c'est que les policiers
sont contre cette réforme
alors vous vous manifestez en tête de
cortège nous on manifeste manifeste dans
les cordons respecte on fait pas de
violence on a baissé les boucliers aller
avec les citoyens pendant 20 minutes
vous avez pas faire comme eux violence
sur le plateau non plus merci et donc je
vous disais aujourd'hui on a parlé des
braves on a parlé des brigades antiques
on voit les images là aujourd'hui vous
dites oui ça risque de basculer mais
pour l'instant l'image qu'on a l'image
forte qu'on a c'est un policier qui à
terre c'est pas un black ah d'accord
donc quand tu as des gens qui vont
foutez vous non c'est votre vision des
choses
pas moi je vous explique pas il existe
des règles d'accord ça a commencé depuis
jeudi ou ça commence à se forcer depuis
l'annonce du 49-3 ou là nous on a dû
s'adapter à une une on va dire un
maintien de l'ordre qui qui a basculé en
violence urbaine c'est-à-dire que les
gens sont fait des jeunes sont rentrés
dans les comme vous le dites ça c'est
pour le coup je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est le seul point où il déjeune sont
rentrés dedans et ne sont pas organiser
là ça fait des petits groupes pour
s'adapter à ça parce qu'ils ont commencé
à brûler des voitures des pardons des
poubelles il voulait s'attaquer au
magasin ils ont commencé
là on a du s'adapter et là on a fait
appel au brave pour justement se
déplacer rapidement d'un point B et
pouvoir empêcher ce genre de choses et
ce genre de violence hier c'était très
calme ça a été très calme parce que les
policiers ils ont figé dans le 9e
arrondissement les gens qui voulaient en
découdre tout simplement on n'a pas vu
les images de du commissariat de Lorient
qu'on a essayé de brûler également et
moi je vous lance un défi monsieur
puisque vous parlez des des actes isolés
sachez que ça il y aura ça ça fera une
mesure d'enquête il va y avoir une
enquête administrative chaque policier
chaque policier et a une caméra piéton
moi j'aimerais bien qu'aujourd'hui on
récupère toutes ces caméras piétons là
toutes les attaques envers les forces de
l'ordre place de la Concorde Porte
d'Italie
ne vient arrondissement Opéra Bastille
avant-hier babastien avant-hier pardon
et on récupérer les cas les images pour
que les policiers n'ont pas le droit
d'exploiter on les mettra sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que là il y a des
journalistes on peut pas dire que les
journalistes sont moi j'espère qu'on
récupère les images des citoyens qui
sont fait massacrer la tête le problème
monsieur c'est quand vous êtes face à un
groupe hostile d'accord qui se trouve à
peu près à 100 m de vous et que vous
dites à des jeunes qui malheureusement
n'ont pas l'habitude de manifester même
s'ils ont une volonté d'exercer leur
colère c'est pas forcément la bonne il
le savent pas ils sont peut-être mal
guidés quand vous faites une sommation
de sommation 3 sommations si les jeunes
se poussent pas oui on utilise des
bâtons de défense pour faire circuler et
pour aller interpeller les individus
avant qu'il s'attaque au commerçants qui
veulent continuer à travailler avant
qu'il s'attaque aux gens qui habitent à
Paris
ça c'est vous qui allez chercher qui est
énorme voilà donc nous on est policiers
on est contre cette réforme mais
maintenant qu'on est sur la voie
publique qu'on doit faire notre travail
on essaie de le faire le maximum alors
je vous le répète vous voulez que tout
ça vous voulez que la violence s'arrête
non mais ça ça moi je vous le dis très
honnêtement ce soir vous voulez qu'il se
passe pas de drame et bah tous les
syndicats de police faites une lettre à
Emmanuel Macron pour qu'il retire sa
tout de suite déjà ça va calmer le jeu
pour leur dire écoutez maintenant ça
suffit nous on constate que sur le
terrain que ça va déborder que ça va
aller trop loin jouer le jeu et puis
baisser les boucliers tournez pas le dos
manifestant marcher avec eux et vous
verrez ils vont plus vous attaquer je
vous jure qu'ils vont plus vous attaquer
au président euh les olives qu'est-ce
qu'il y a Mathieu mais qui êtes-vous au
niveau livre pour poser un ultimatum au
président que vous avez encore une fois
élu pardon pour les lunettes que vous
avez encore une fois et alors je vais
dire Mathieu relative par relative élu
sur tu la veux la vérité
dis-lui ta vérité la vérité vous l'avez
élu sur sur un programme qui était même
à 65 ans qui est passé à 60 de dire vous
s'il te plaît attends pardon tu après il
y a eu le PGE qui a que tout le monde et
après la vraie vérité ce que personne ne
dit ce qui a tué ce pays c'est l'Ukraine
c'est que le vrai débat c'est est-ce que
nous on doit à ce point aider l'Ukraine
alors attention je suis d'accord
tu as raison tu as raison et c'est pas
lui et sa retraite tu comprends ce que
je veux dire par contre là dessus je
suis entièrement d'accord avec toi les
décisions gouvernementales qui
aujourd'hui est là je me rappelle de
cette phrase on pourrait d'ailleurs la
répéter à tout le monde nous allons
assécher économiquement la Russie moi je
pense qu'il a séché économiquement les
citoyens je suis entièrement d'accord
avec toi Mathieu franchement je suis
d'accord avec toi
entièrement d'accord donc Olivier donc
toi c'est quoi ta première idée c'est ça
c'est que demander aux syndicats
aujourd'hui il faut que le gouvernement
s'ils veulent que ça se désamorce
premièrement mais c'est vraiment qu'un
début il faut qu'il enlève cette réforme
et qui donne des résultats
pour l'instant faut l'enlever si il veut
que ça se désamorce faut qu'il l'enlève
60 ans comme Mélenchon et Marine je suis
pas en train de parler
pour l'instant on la remet dans
l'urgence là on est dans l'urgence on la
remet comme à l'été ça va désamorcer et
on donne des réponses tout de suite aux
citoyens dans le pouvoir d'achat dont
j'ai peur c'est que je vois pas le
gouvernement reculer c'est là c'est un
bras de fer on est à quelques jours de
la de la réponse du Conseil d'État il
faut que le Conseil des temps réagisse
il va passer enfin je sais alors moi
pour moi 99 ça va passer je suis
d'accord avec toi mais aujourd'hui tu
veux pas se taper la honte Macron ils
disent j'ai pas reculé bah il fait les
accords comme il a fait les accords avec
les républicains pour pouvoir passer le
49-3 il leur dit bon allez accepter pas
et puis faites en sorte que dégage enfin
moi je vous dis je le répète les gens
qui pensent que dur comme faire que
c'est Redford c'est réformes est bonne
tant mieux pour eux ils ont le droit ce
qu'il faut juste constater c'est que tu
as plus de 70 % de la population qui
n'en veut pas et aujourd'hui on a un
gros problème qui est en train de
grandir ce soir ça va être pire on vient
de m'envoyer les images c'est terrible
demain franchement je vois pas les
choses se désamorcer
moi j'ai vu rien là les syndicats alors
exactement c'est exactement exactement
dis les choses il faut arrêter de dire
les syndicats dans les syndicats vous
avez les représentants syndicaux et vous
avez les syndiqués moi je vous dis les
représentants syndicaux ne tiennent même
plus les syndiqués on a vu aujourd'hui
ils ont pris un bus ils l'ont mis pour
faire une barrière des voitures ils ont
chercher les portiques vous inquiétez
pas aussi aussi les syndiqués ils vont
bien plus loin et il est tiennent plus
les responsables syndicaux ils tiennent
plus leurs syndiqués et là le
gouvernement là où il doit commencer à
réfléchir c'est qu'il tient plus les
choses parce que les syndicats bien sûr
qu'il les tiens on les met dans le
bureau on fait un petit accord avec le
représentant syndicaux on sait tous
comment que ça se passe là aujourd'hui
on parle du peuple c'est le peuple qui
est dans la rue c'est pas les
représentants syndicaux c'est pas les
politiques c'est pas tout ça mais non
mais c'est sûr donc toi pour toi ça va
ça va s'envenimer dans les prochains
jours s'il y a aucune réponse du
gouvernement je vois pas je vois pas
comment ça pourrait se désamorcer et je
le répète le malheur c'est que tu vas je
le répète encore il va arriver un drame
il va arriver à réel drame donc si
Macron il veut pas qu'il y a un drame
aujourd'hui dans son pays parce que le
seul responsable de ce drame ça sera
Emmanuel Macron il sera responsable